[Applause]
how are you yeah great welcome to the
show thank you I'm so honored I love you
I'm so happy to be here oh I hope you
we're stoked to have you I was so
excited so people know you from Teen
Wolf yeah okay but you're musical as
well I am so I learned that you started
even songwriting as a kid I did I had
influences my favorite band was Blink
182 when I was like seven years old and
so anything I I just wanted to be oh wow
look at that gosh yeah I was an actual
full-on fanatic of Blink-182 still like
a lot of us were yes and are yes it's a
great band and it was like I feel like
for Our Generation I'm older than you
but our generation it was like it was
like I don't know the first kind of punk
thing that for me like absolutely yeah
yeah okay so going back to music so do
you remember the first song you ever
wrote Because I I remember mine you do
yeah no you need to know it I just mean
I think it stays with you for some
reason it does stay away not a lot of
things from like my 11 and 12 year old
years stay with me but that song for
some reason and it's also a weird song
It's a song that a 12 year old shouldn't
have written partly because like I grew
up listening to Blink 182 and they
always had some fart joke or some adult
joke yeah in there and so I wrote a song
about having a Mojo which I got from I
think Austin Powers Mojo do you remember
I love it you're so young but yes yes
not when you were a kid when that came
out sure I was I was it was pretty it
was great I was like 12 years old yeah
maybe I love Austin Powers yes yes so
you wrote about your mojo I wrote about
my mojo at 12 years old at 12 years old
how was your mojo at 12 years old
I don't know if I had any game or any
Mojo
um but yeah I wrote I wrote a little
song I love that I just love how it
sticks with you oh I am I think we
that's so weird we kind of had your
guitar plays behind the couch what and
I'm just thinking weird as well first of
all I want to show you this guitar right
this is a badass guitar
yeah cool right what yeah are these like
there's a blink on here somewhere Dead
Kennedys yeah it's a punk rock different
languages you have a palm tree for
happiness I love all of this yeah cool I
just wondered if you could because I
know we remember these I remember my
first song so what how does yours go so
last night I wrote the guitar to it
because I didn't want to sing acapella I
felt a little awkward oh okay I could
have okay um I think this is cooler but
I wrote I wrote the guitar to it last
night okay but the melody is the same
and the lyrics are the same I swear a
couple of times in the lyrics so I'm
changing those okay or we could just
bleep you but go for it they're keeping
it classy yeah I like it go ahead you
actually have the stature
awesome Stay classy San Diego exactly
okay how's it going I wrote this when I
was 12. okay here's the thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that I love you I love that song it's so
Punk it's a little punk no no it
absolutely I grew up listening to punk
rock pop punk in that like it's one of
my favorite songs ever yeah and I know
how to play the entire thing and it
because it is it it reminds me of punk
roots oh that's
really does yeah that made me feel cool
all right it's awesome
it's one of my favorites to sing just
because everybody loves singing it even
grown ass men in the audience cheers
okay so here's Mojo
oh
[Music]
today I woke up a different person it
seems like I have no reason to live up
with a hundred excuses and I'm so gosh
darn useless but one's cool with a total
Mojo no more one two three go
and that's that's it
catchy right yeah
yeah I was like
I was like I didn't have to fake it be
like that's cool that's cool though
thank you yeah that's like really catchy
I mean all my influences you including
are like catchy badass that was really
rad I'm probably going to be singing
that later and hate you for it but you
know when you can't get out of your head
that was really mine wasn't that cool
I'm not gonna talk about mine okay
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going home
[Music]